[Applause]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions it's the ramsy show we help
people build wealth do work that they
love and create actual amazing
relationships George camell Ramsey
personality host of The George camel
popular YouTube show and co-host of the
super popular smart money happy hour
is my co-host today we're back live and
at it as you folks are hey have you got
the cobwebs blown out from the eggnog
yet are you back at it are you ready to
rock and roll is a game on is there a
reset is there a cycle that needs to be
broken my buddy joo's got everybody
resetting and we're breaking the cycle
so whatever it is you got to do there's
got to be a thing and you got to do
something different you got to set these
New Year's resolutions in process make a
habit happen and uh one of the things
that we want you to make a habit of is
making sure you go ahead and order
George's book it comes out next week
next week George that's crazy yeah so
you can just for a couple more days get
all of the pre-sale elements with it and
it's called Breaking Free from broke the
ultimate guide for more money and less
stress and it's a very Millennial cover
uh but it's only it's not just for
Millennials that's right 25 to 55
anywhere in there or a little younger a
little older 15 to 55 there we go well a
lot of people are saying hey what is the
book I can give to my team that they'll
actually listen to it is is but I hope
this is the year people break free from
broke Dave there's too many people out
there and it's not about income we're
having people call in and make 200 Grand
oh no income's everywhere and they're
drowning in payments a lot of lot of
people would make a lot of money and
spend it all this is the year think
they're in Congress or something I think
America's going to unplug from The
Matrix this year because they're sick of
this toxic money culture of debt and
payments and they're stressed out about
what's going to happen in the economy
and I just want to hold the financial
mirror up and go you're going to solve
this it's not up to anyone else that's
it that's how it's done so the book
comes out next week if you order the $20
book today you get about $100 worth of
goodies with it including a couple
months of every dollar oh that comes
with it anyway that's right whether you
buy before or after three months of
every dollar premium the audio book
which is going to be enhanced with some
cool production the ebook audio book
it's going to be the best audio book
we've ever done I love EXT extra
production on it yeah um we got a live
event happening the launch week that
you'll get access to as well as a video
talk I did called show the money all if
you pre-order yeah so about $100 worth
of stuff if you pre-order right now
Breaking Free from broke so we'll start
the year with a commercial but we'll
keep going so the deal is that um and I
want to I'm actually going to carry this
over in the next segment because I just
looked up and saw how much time I spent
yaking about nothing but the uh um sorry
about that guys that was one of my New
Year's resolutions to not do that stop
yaking it's not uh no I can't stop
yaking it's like quiet out there if you
do that but the the um
um set setting and keeping goals because
the thing we have figured out that is
unique at
Ramsay that the rest of the financial
world still struggles with basically is
that personal finan is 80% Behavior it's
20% head
knowledge you really fix the person in
your mirror or you're just
screwed I mean you're just not g if you
keep doing what you've been doing you're
going to keep getting what you've been
getting and continuing to do the same
thing over and over again expect a
different result is the definition of
insanity and so it is time to break free
from the cycle and that's why we're
doing this live stream called that as
well but the the but I want to talk
about that in this next segment a minute
and but let's set that up a second
because I don't think any of you want to
miss this next segment it's it's really
de dialing into from a business
perspective treating your life like it's
a business how am I going to set my
Revenue goals my expense goals and my
profit goals you know that's what you do
for business you set a budget and uh how
am I going to do that in my personal
situation because everybody's a little
bit introspective this time of year you
know I got an email from a friend of
mine's doing dry January so everybody's
going to try to do something to be a
little better version of themselves
right and um I I think you should anyway
yeah I mean we have a lot of areas finan
is what we focus on but now with Dr John
delone here we're covering mental health
goals and relationship ship goals and
Ken Coleman's got work goals if you want
to up your career and so it's expanded
and you've talked about how you you
don't want a flat tire in any area of
life as well where you You're great with
your finances but your marriage is on
the brink you've got to excel in all the
areas yeah or you're a great parent but
you're broke all the time you know
that's that ends up by definition
eventually not being a great parent you
know by definition and and so but if you
work all the time and you never see your
kids you got a pile of money then you
you you know again you're out of balance
and people talk about life balance bance
but um I don't want to talk about it in
that sense cuz sometimes that's code for
I want to do I just want to go over here
and not do anything call that life
balance um I want to I want to kick back
and call that life balance no I want you
to kick in I want you to get it I want
you to get after it and whatever the
area is that you need to attack I want
you to do it you know wholesale and wide
open so you know basically I'm not
talking about
dreaming uh you know dreaming is good
having a dream is a good thing being a
Dre dreamer has a negative no want no
one wants their kid to marry a dreamer
yeah hey Dad I'm getting engaged and
he's a dreamer oh crap they're going to
live in the basement that's code for
unemployed that's code for I'm me I
don't do much yeah so you don't want to
be a dreamer but having vision is a good
thing well having a dream is a good
thing but just only the ne the negative
connotation is a dreamer means without
action and so you want to step into
action and 41% of Americans make New
Year's goals or resolutions only 8% in
end up keeping them I don't I can't
believe it's that high only 8% I would
have guessed lower than that but we're
going to talk about in this next segment
exactly how to lay out for any area of
your life how to lay out a
goal and how to make it work and how to
stick to it for the rest of this year so
if you've kind of had a oh I lay or
maybe you're really game on well I'm
going to give you a little bit a little
fine tuning for that next time next
segment here a and we're going to lay it
out in a way that that you're not going
to be confused at all about what it
takes to win in any given area and
bottom line is it takes your mirror that
person that they have to step up well I
you teach this in entree leadership a
lot but I love the business analogy
going hey what if we treated our
personal life like it was a business
like there was really something on the
line because a lot of times when it's
just us Dave we can let ourselves down
all day long but you can't do that in
business and I think we need to have
that level of of gravity when it comes
to our goals this year yeah I'm going to
get around to investing
someday but not treat it like it matters
well you ought to treat it like it
really matters because it does I mean
retiring and eating Alpo is not a plan
you know retiring and having the the you
know the dad blame government you're
living on social insecurity after
working your whole life you're going to
let the government which is well known
for its ability to handle money take
care of you that's a dumb
plan that that's a definition of
mediocrity minus about six degrees so
you don't want to do that but that's
what's going to happen if you're on
Coast mode you can Coast through the
society and have a relatively decent
lifestyle high stress but relatively
decent lifestyle instead I would rather
just turn on the turn up the heat and
let's go get it let's go do something
different and all that leads to more
peace more confidence less stress that's
what this is all about so stay it's
going to be good stay tuned for the uh
magic formula nothing magic about Dave's
laying out the secrets for can you
believe the show secrets and there is no
magic I just hate to tell you all that
it's just Grandma's Old Common Sense
that'll work those of you that want to
lose weight here I'll help you with it
eat
less
whoa saved your money for a DI you and
Jenny Craig got got something going on
saved it for saved the money on a diet
book you can use it for one of ours this
is the Ramsey
Show
[Music]
hey if you're in over your head with
student loans and tired of getting calls
from collection agencies if private
student loan debt is taking away your
financial piece and you don't see any
way out you need y refi they're not a a
debt settlement company and they're not
connected to a bank why refi refinances
defaulted private student loans that
other places won't touch and gives you a
custom loan built for you based on your
ability to pay so when you refinance
your private student loan debt with Y
refi you'll have a payment you can
afford with a low fixed interest rate
you couldn't get anywhere else to help
you stick to your budget and work the
debt snowball and you can save thousands
of dollars to learn more about this
custom refinancing option and a lumpsum
payoff option you could qualify for
after 24 months call
8442 Ramsey or go to Y rei.com
[Music]
Ramsey
George camel Ramsey personality is my
co-host today welcome the ramsy show
folks we're glad you're here this is a
show that actually helps you want to win
at your life uh we started years ago
talking about your money we still talk
about money a lot but we talk about
every area of your life we were talking
before the break there
about dreams dreams with work clothes on
are called
goals and you better put some work
clothes on if you want to get something
done um you know it's funny to me that
every time I'm lucky it's usually around
the time I'm wearing work clothes um my
luck tends to happen the more I work
it's just this honest correlation you
know I get more luck the more I work and
that's pretty simple the way this is so
dreams that put their work clothes on
are called goals
now a lot of people talk about setting
goals but let me tell you if you don't
set the goal
correctly you have zero chance almost of
hitting it and it has to have really
there are five
components of a properly set goal and if
you dodge any of them you lower your
probability of hitting it almost to zero
the first three for sure if you don't do
the first three you're just done there's
not there's almost no chance you're
going to hit it the so I want to lose
weight I want to make more money I want
to
uh have a better career I want to
graduate from college uh I want to
whatever so the first two things a goal
has to be is you if you say I want to
lose weight you're not going
to that's not enough that's a Dream It's
fuzzy the first two things a goal has to
be specific and it has to be measurable
so a go losing weight is a measurable
event earning more money is a measurable
event I want to get out of debt that's a
measurable event now we've got to get
very very specific how much and by when
that's a that's another piece of the
puzzle here the third one is time limit
yeah when you have those three together
it's magic cuz now it's reality yeah
well when you put those three together
math automatically happens so you know
let's just use the weight example A lot
of people talking about that this time
of year I want to lose weight you won't
okay that it's measurable but it's not
spefic okay how much do you want to lose
oh 30 lb okay now we measurable and
specific now then the question is do you
want to lose 30 lb over 10 years and how
many times do you want to lose 30
pounds that's an important piece of the
puzzle yeah so you know you I want to
earn more money great how much I want to
earn $100,000 this year okay how how how
soon do you want to do it now when you
put a time limit on it and you know what
the amount is automatically your brain
starts doing sixth grade math
long division right so if I want to lose
30 lbs when I want to do it over 3
months I say instantly everyone said
that's 10 pounds a month instantly
you're going some of you are even going
further and saying that's 2 and a half
pounds a week and then you start
automatically saying what has to be true
that's not true now and so I'm going to
raise my water intake lower the bread
and sugar intake and um increase my uh
aerobic activity to 30 minutes a day
these are magical things that you do if
you're losing weight right if I want to
earn more money okay well are you're on
commission you need to make more sales
right so how many more calls do you need
to make to make the sales I had a guy
tell me one time he said I'm going to
earn 100 he's working for us he said I'm
going to earn $100,000 this year and I
said no you're
not he said what do you mean you're not
going to pay me and I said no you you I
I read the sales reports you don't make
enough calls to make enough sales on
average with our average order value on
that call to make $100,000
and and so how many you know $100,000 is
8,333 a month that's $2,100 a week what
are you going to do to earn $2,100 a
week and then you figure that out then
and what's it take to do that and you're
willing to do those steps boom you've
done the long division you've done the
math right I'm going to pay off you know
a lot of times people call in and they
go well you know I've got $75,000 in
debt okay what do you make well I make
$660,000 okay if you pay off $25,000 a
year that's 3 years so instantly we're
doing we're setting goals with you when
you call in here for you uh but also
inspiring You by showing you that you
know if you did roll up your sleeves
earn a little bit more money and lived
on less than you make you could pay off
$225,000 a year that's $2,000 a month
you do that for three years you paid off
$75,000 you start to do the math and
then the math gives you hope cuz you can
really do 30 pounds in in three months
that's not an unreasonable loss for most
people now you shouldn't do that you
would disappear I would float away Into
The Ether if I did that that just one of
my legs would be smaller but you know
that's all but the uh but you know other
people are right so everybody's got a
different thing but 30 pounds is doable
30 PBS is doable you got you have to
make the goal reasonable but you want it
to be a little bit scary I think it's
too easy let me tell you what if you
don't write it down that's the the
fourth one it makes it hard to do too
once you write it out there's something
that happens the Bible says write the
vision and make it plain it says it in
habach one of the Old Testament books
write the vision and make it plain so
when you write down I am going to lose
30 lb 10 lb a month 30 lb in 90 days 10
lb a month 2 and2 pounds a week then you
step up on the scales and you're up a
pound you got you got a baseline you go
now I got three and a half pounds I'm
screwed you know I really got to get out
of the cookies here I mean you you start
to make the adjustments of what you've
got to do put up the Christmas cookies
there's enough already I'm talking to
myself now but the but the uh but I mean
I'm going to I'm going to pay off this
debt if I'm going to pay off $2,000 a
month and you look up and you've only
paid off a th000 well you're off goal
and when you write out your debt
snowball when you write out your budget
which is your monthly goals for money
then you've got it in writing if you
want to earn more put it in writing and
then start talking about what you're
going to do to cause that to happen cuz
something has to be different for you to
be different Hello if you want to be out
of debt and you're in debt something has
to be
different so what's going to be
different oh I'm selling some crap I
mean we're amputating the Tahoe here uh
that that boat that's been sitting out
there in the yard that we act like we
use and we don't use it's gone I mean
you know yes I have a $9,000 riding
lawnmower I'm an idiot so I'm selling it
yes okay I mean you're an idiot if you
have $9,000 riding lawn mower and and
you owe $99,000 on it now if you if
you're a billionaire and you have a
$9,000 running you P cash you pay cash
that's okay that's an idiotic butt thing
to do people do that so sacrifices must
be made well something has to change and
generally it feel change always feels
like a sacrifice it may not be as
sacrificial as you think it may be you
just look up and you go oh there's
$50,000 in my savings account I owe
$35,000 on this stupid but student loan
and apparently Joe Biden is not coming
to the rescue hello are you just now
waking up to that and so I mean he can't
even find anyway but the um yeah so oh
my gosh are you just now W so if the
change could simply be you're going to
reduce your savings account by $35,000
Ready set go boom done it's still going
to hurt a little bit tap out done just
like that and the last one is the goals
have to be your
goal that's the unexpected one in the
mix here well other people let people
set goals for them my mama always wanted
me to be a dentist I'm not going to you
my parents told me I should stop wasting
money on rent and buy a house yeah
that's a terrible reason to buy a house
yeah and and yet didn't fund any of this
suggestion nope you know they don't pay
your bills my friend said I should
always have a car payment yeah but he
ain't paying it so hello you know oh
people are always people always got
opinions about everybody else's stuff
and you know my dad always wanted to be
a be a preacher I'm not going to your
church unless you're talking about God
your dad God the father but other than
that I don't you know for people whose
Earthly father called them into the
Ministries they don't make good pastors
hello and so you know I all you know but
you need to say so my wife wants me to
lose 30
PBS that's a is that a trick question no
it's not a trick question it won't work
until I want to lose 30 I I could want
to do it to please her that's really
that's really horrible that's that's
wastified right there I mean my wife
wants me to earn more money no that
won't work my mama always wanted me to I
don't care what your mama wants it's
time to be a grownup if you're 25 your
problems are now your problems you can't
blame them on your parents anymore
you're like an adult walking around in
like a large body and stuff and you need
to freaking act like it so you can't the
days of blaming Mama and Daddy are done
so that expired exactly now seven areas
we recommend you set goals for certainly
financial goals intellectual goals
you're going to read a book this year
how many non-fiction books are you going
to read this year there's a direct
correlation between your income and the
level of non-fiction books you read read
a
book family goals how you going to break
that out spiritual goals prayer time
Bible reading going to church physical
goals we talked about losing weight
exercising run a marathon career goals
social goals you should set goals in
these areas and they should be specific
they should be measurable they should be
in writing and they need to be your
goals not you living someone else's life
otherwise it doesn't work this is the
ramsy
[Music]
show
if you're like most people your home is
your most valuable asset and when you
want to make improvements it can feel
like everything costs too much or takes
too long but something as simple as
custom window coverings from blinds.com
can completely change your space and add
value to your home we've recommended
blinds.com for over a decade so you know
you can trust them from blinds drapes
and shut to motorized Shades they make
it easy and affordable to upgrade your
entire home and their team is ready to
help with everything from design
consultation to measuring and
installation plus there are never any
misleading quotes or hidden fees
everything's backed by their 100%
satisfaction guarantee and shipping is
always free Cy blinds.com is the number
one online retailer of custom window
coverings visit blinds.com to save up to
40% off everything sitewide go to
blinds.com for more
[Music]
information
George camel Ramsey personality is my
co-host today Alyssa is with us in
Naples Florida hi Alyssa welcome to the
Ramsey
Show hi hey what's
up oh not much just taking a break in my
workday okay how can we
help so um I just got remarried in
October and my husband and I you know
after the wedding really sat down and
took a a good look at our combined
finances Good and we definitely made a
lot of uh debt choices independently and
now coming together trying to figure out
how we can tackle that hopefully you
know for the new year planning on you
know having a kid um I already have a 9
old daughter and trying to get those you
know figured out so that we're not
constantly worried about savings and
being able to
retire sounds like you need to do all
the things that all of us need to
do yeah feed babies retire get out of
debt save money right right um and part
of the thing that that's a little bit
frustrating is you know between our
combined finances we're bringing in
about
11,500 a month and still feel like we
can't you know we've only got about
3,000 that our savings um not able to
really contribute to retirement or
anything like that so trying to figure
out how much debt do you
have um so student debt we've got about
140,000 um who's the
law I'm the mental health therapist ah
okay so I've I've got I've got about
about
90 um he he has about 40 and that was
you know from the his parents pushing
him to go to college um so he has debt
with no real what other debt have
nothing really to show for it um car
payments um about 60,000 total in our
cars you ow 60 on your cars
okay um and then we've got uh a mortgage
that's got about
240,000
M okay that's as far as debt
goes okay so Alyssa looking at these
numbers Let's ignore the mortgage for
now and focus on the Consumer Debt
you've got about 190 or so in Consumer
Debt and you guys are bringing home what
130 140 Grand M and so this becomes a
great math equation where we go how much
of margin can we create every month to
throw at that smallest debt that's all
we're focused on no saving no investing
we're not eating out we got to make some
sacrifices here how quickly could you
pay off you know could you throw three
four $5,000 a month at the smallest
debt
tried I think for me it's the fear with
my daughter um making sure that we have
enough because with me with me being
self-employed and him doing construction
and things like that I get worried about
catastrophic expenses you know what I'm
worried about you make $130,000 a year
and you're freaking broke that's what
I'm worried about I think you need to be
worried about that you're driving cars
you can't afford and you have a
lifestyle that's absolutely
asinine and that's nothing to do with a
nine-year-old what what does she need
that's thousands of dollars a month
worth when you say I need to take care
of her it's more it's more just in case
yeah you know well there's no bit but
you're not doing anything about it you
got
$3,000 so that's a complete red herring
that's absolutely you're not you're
doing nothing about that except creating
anxiety right yeah so it's time it's
time for a pinion for Action some
urgency here and say okay the more
dramatic we more dramatic we change our
life the more dramatically we change our
life the more sacrificially we change
our
life the the faster this is going to
turn around and we're going to have a
pile of cash and we'll be out of debt
Yeah the more you just goof around with
it cuz here's the deal you guys just you
guys have no idea where this money goes
right and so we're going to get you on a
detailed written budget so here's the
thing what kind of mental mental health
professional what kind of work do you do
um so I do counseling like therapy
depression anxiety stuff like that okay
all right and so what you do is is is
there's some parallels to what we do so
you can use you can be physician heal
thyself okay um so cuz here's the thing
you you are an objective Observer to
someone's
misbehavior right and you look at that
and go hey you ought to try this because
the way you've been doing it not working
you know this yelling and screaming at
your wife not working you know this zero
activity sitting in a dark room adding
your to your depression so you need
sunlight and vitamin D and activ so you
need to and exercise and be in sunlight
helps with depression am I
wrong no so you send you send somebody
because you're in but they're sitting in
the dark room they don't see it so what
I want to do here is I just want you to
say okay if I hired you you're a smart
person if I hired you even though you're
not a financial professional it's
because the stuff we're dealing with
here is sixth grade math if I hired you
to look at this and say you come in
objectively and you look at this family
they make $13 $140,000 year they have
$3,000 their name they have $660,000 in
car debt and they have student loans
have been hanging around so long they
think they're a pet they feel stuck you
could objectively look in from the
outside like you do every day and look
at this the way George and I are looking
at it right now going uh these people
need to tighten things up they need to
sell a car or two uh they're not going
on vacation cuz they're broke cuz and if
they're sick and tired of being sick and
tired you'll change your process and if
you cuz you if you look at this
objectively from the outside I can see
in a three minute radio conversation
with you I I can see 40 or $50,000 a
year here that you could throw at this
and you'd be out of debt in no time but
it's going to mean you're driving
different cars you're not going on
vacation you're not eating out and uh
it's not going to be comfortable for a
while until you set some new grooves in
your
brain
yeah so we definitely already decided on
completely cutting out
vacations okay we had like huge
conversations you know with family of
like go you know even like big family
Crews and just saying sorry we can't do
it um You're Gonna Learn to say no a
whole lot yeah say no so you can say yes
the way we say it is you live like no
one else so that later you can live and
give like no one else so if I were
prescribing to you from the outside
looking in the way I'm asking you to do
for yourself I could look at these
numbers and say these people have a
really tough 2 and 1 half years ahead of
them so that they have an awesome life
the rest of their
life yeah and it's worth it and it works
because it is just math it's just sixth
grade math but it has to do with
controlling my the the the angry little
boy or little girl that lives inside of
each of us and making that little person
who throws a fit on the cereal aisle and
wants Fruity Pebbles no no cuz that
little kid he rises up I want a new car
I I deserve I mean I have a I have a
master's degree I deserve a good car no
you don't you're freaking broke you
deserve Freedom not this life of stress
and the math does give me hope in the
situation make 11 the beautiful story
about your the beautiful part about your
story is Alyssa you um you have the
income and the parallel would be if you
were sitting with a patient who is um
Master's degreed in something you you
they have the intellect to adjust their
mental behaviors to to adjust their
mental health with behavior shifts that
you with directions you can give them
they have the capacity and you didn't
call me up making $30,000 with these
numbers thank God you call me up making
$130,000 with these numbers yeah so you
can do this and the correlation is very
simple the deeper you cut the more
sacrificial and weird you are and it's
going to feel very strange for the first
90 days um and then it'll get to be a
normal Rhythm but the deeper you cut the
faster you're out by the way that works
for all of you the deeper you cut the
faster you're out and uh I'm I'mma rip
the Band-Aid off guy yeah just uh pull
it off one hair at a time thing no thank
you that's a lot of pain well that's why
you like to amputate the Tahoe just do
the big stuff knock it out it's a stupid
car you'll get another one stupid car
there's more tah I got a lot of stupid
cars now and you know but I didn't used
to I mean it's a stupid car it's a
stupid house you know it's just stuff
and you can get you some more stuff but
you can't get your life back
this is the Ramsey
[Music]
[Applause]
Show hey guys I've told you before about
Christian Healthcare Ministries a Health
cost sharing Ministry but listen to
Jenna a chm member she says one of my
biggest concerns about entrepreneurship
and motherhood was figuring out how to
take care of our health expenses but we
have found a solution that works for us
in an incredible way she loves that with
chm she can help other families who need
it and receive help back when her own
family has an eligible medical event chm
has been a godsend for Jenna that's her
chm story and it could be yours learn
more and join at chministries.org
[Music]
budget
[Applause]
George camel Ramsey personality is my
co-host today Luke is in Tuscaloosa
Alabama where they are crying this
morning hey Luke welcome to the uh ramsy
show not too many TS to clean up this
morning on my how's everything
going better than I deserve oh my
goodness tell me uh how we can help
today uh yes sir um I'm just looking to
uh get a plan together on uh possibly
buying a house uh not necessarily in a
set time frame um dating a girl
currently that kind of has her stopwatch
clicking on me and I don't want to go
through the whole Renning process if I
don't have to so uh we're just kind of
wanting to get your's opinion on that so
you've got a girlfriend she's wanting
you to propose you're wanting to buy a
house there's a lot going on here and
you're wondering when is the time to buy
a
house um yes sir how old are you uh I'm
24 when will you get
married uh probably in the next year and
a half or
so you got any
money uh I currently have about
53,000 uh sitting I know y going to get
upset with me but uh in a second account
I'm not upset with you I'm happy you're
24 years old got 50 Grand that's fair
that's that's you're stud man I thought
you going to say but I have 100,000 in
debt you got any debt oh no sir
currently uh looking at the parents and
have been blessed that they have given
me that opportunity that's incredible I
would just stack up as much cash as you
can until this wedding and we'll cash
flow it and then we'll talk about buying
a house but I wouldn't do it before you
guys are married no I would she's going
to want a different house than you the
one you picked out oh that is 100% for
certain
okay yeah so um ideal is you guys pile
up as much cash as you can and somewhere
around a year after the wedding you're
purchasing okay that's ideal the reason
that's ideal is it gives you enough time
of being married folk to make a better
decision together because you'll make a
better decision after you've been
married a year than you will one after
you've been married one
week okay and you because you will have
learned to work together on other things
as well during that year that first year
of marriage is very interesting so um
you know you just take that time get to
know her she gets to know you and the
way we always joke about it is we say it
takes about a year to know how far away
from your mother-in-law to
buy but that you know that's about
that's about the measure so um but that
you know there's some truth in that joke
that's why it's funny but the uh uh but
yeah that that's that's what we look at
and and but that means you're going to
be like uh 26 years old which is okay
with
me it also means you're probably going
to have
$100,000 yes sir which is okay with me
love it does she have any
debt uh not that I'm aware of um she
comes from a pretty well off family that
doesn't mean a thing oh I know it
doesn't mean a thing but from what I've
heard and seen it doesn't look like she
does okay okay that just might delay it
if she did but it sounds like you guys
are both going to get married completely
debt-free with a pile of money in the
bank which is the best case scenario
before you start talking about putting a
ring on on uh this finger as an
engagement you need to know everything
about her financial life and she needs
to know everything about yours yes sir
now one follow-up question um what do
you suggest I do um because obviously
$53,000 sitting in the bank is not doing
me any good I mean it's doing me a lot
of good just sitting there but I feel
like I could use it elsewhere you know
Finance or some kind of account with a
Financial Manager of some sort I don't
think I'd get fancy you might do a high
yield savings account which might pay
you in this current world what three or
4% something like that instead of a half
a percent if the bank I don't know what
the bank's paying you but talk to that
bank about a high yield savings account
if they don't have one shop around and
find one what are those paying that
you're yeah I'm I got one that's about
5% right now but you can easily find one
that are in the four range yeah four and
five is but I really don't I'm not going
to try to get rich on this money I just
don't want to lose it and I want to I
want to be with it which is what you're
asking I don't want you pay a half a
percent or something silly sitting in
checking but you got like a 2-year time
Horizon you don't want to go investing
in the market and all of a sudden your
account dipped 20% because of a bad year
yeah you're not going to buy a house
because of the amount of money this
account makes you're going to buy a
house because of how wise you are
putting money into this account the
savings rate for sure that's where
that's where this money's coming from
Johns in Rock Hill South Carolina hey
John welcome to the ramsy show
hey there thank you so much for having
me better than great man how can we
help all right so my question is I'm on
baby step number two just kind of
started following y'all stuff and I'm
super stoked about it um my wife and I
are teachers and we are set to have some
loans forgiven not through the Public
service loan program because I have
learned through y'all that that is not a
good route to go but um our state South
Carolina will forgive loans um for
teaching in high areas of need um wife
is special ed teacher and I teach out a
school with like lowincome students yeah
at what rate do they forgive it so they
actually don't forgive it they pay
it yes yes uh um so my mine can be uh
they will forgive up to 5,000 after five
years of teaching $5,000 after five
years yes o that's nothing okay what's
the other one um so they will forgive uh
17,500 of my wives after five
years okay so that's $5,000 a year no no
it's not five years you said oh neither
one of these we're screwing with y'all
need to just get out of debt just go
ahead because total we have
64,000 yeah but 225 of that is you're
waiting Five Years on $22,000 now I
don't I want you to have a
life yeah and you won't be locked in
some of these things forgive like
$10,000 a year and none of the ones
you're doing do that so that's why I was
asking how it worked but um no that's
not that's not generous enough for me to
be wanting to stay in debt and also to
have the golden handcuffs you may decide
to change the direction of your teaching
career and you don't want a lousy
thousand a year Mo motivating you on
that right um so follow up with that
I'll be to the point I only have one
year left until I could get that 5,000
well that makes a difference okay yeah I
I'll take it then if it's one year I
thought we were starting Ready set go
today what about your wife what about
your wife how long to the
175 yes sir she has uh three years left
um so that is a little more touch and go
I'm I'm probably okay with both of those
now that you changed my time
Horizon um would you guys stay in those
careers in those areas if this wasn't on
the table one year he will so take the
five grand but her three years sure I
will um the the question is with her um
special ed is just a very difficult
field umer support is is not where it
needs to be and we have a one-ear old
and one on the way so her ability to
stay in the field we we're not really
sure with that so yeah I'm leaning
towards like hey should we just pay it
off I'm with that I'm with that or
here's the other thing you could do and
this is what I was going to recommend at
the close of the call is go ahead and
set a separate savings account up with
that amount of money in
it to where you have paid it off it's in
your debt snowball but you're holding
the money and then the day she decides I
want to be with my babies instead of the
string of strain of this job uh boom you
pull a trigger right the check it's
done ah okay that's that's that's very
smart Okay that takes a pressure off of
her to stay in the job uh pass when she
should um with little babies and then uh
but your five is going to be here in 20
minutes I mean right right you don't
even have to if you want to set that
aside too until the five hits you can
but um it just gives you an extra bump
towards your baby step 3 emergency fund
then cuz you still got what 40 grand
left after even after both are would be
forgiven uh pretty much unfortunately we
both have Masters um in teaching and um
so yeah what's your household
income uh household income is uh
teaching salaries is 105 and then I work
in the summer so it's about 115
altogether good for you okay good very
cool well I mean you're going to be okay
you're going to be fine it's just a
matter of kind of analyzing the you know
where the squeeze meets the juice right
and and yeah that I so always if even if
there's a forgiveness program we go
along with we say set the money aside in
savings which keep takes away the golden
handcuffs that's the big thing you want
to do there so good question man good
question you're sound like you're a good
dad a good husband proud of you keep it
up Happy New Year this is the Ramsey
[Music]
Show
live from the headquarters of ramsy
solutions it's the ramsy show where we
help people build wealth
do work that they love and create actual
amazing
relationships George camel Ramsey
personality is my co-host today open
phones at
88255 225 thank you for joining us and
happy New Year to you Dalton is with us
in Indianapolis to start this hour hi
Dalton welcome to the ramsy
show Hello thank you for having me sure
what's
up so about a year ago um
soon after I got my first job I invested
into an i iul due to talking to my
parents financial advisor and since
after having kind of see some of your
work and I saw I one of the videos you
guys talking about it and I kind of
looked into it myself I kind of decided
I would like to get out of this however
the problem is is there's a surrender
charge so I have about um I've been
invested since last November and I have
about like $1,500 invested but if I were
to try I can't transfer it into anything
else if I try to leave it I'd be left
with
$400 and the surrender charge isn't go
away until like another 10 years and I'd
have to keep investing so I'm not sure
what to do about
this well it sounds like you've lost
$1,100 to
me yeah and um yeah make note that this
guy screwed
you MH putting you into this product I
mean put you in a product that the only
way you avoid surrender charges is 10
years mhm oh man how old are you uh 20
good Lord man I'm sorry this is we file
this one under stupid tax and we've all
paid our version of it but I hate that
you have to deal with this and lose at
11100 the only the only other option is
continue to pay them money and lose even
more yeah what are you paying into this
thing um it's 150 a month what do you
make um 22,000 a year my gosh gosh what
do you do for a living
Dalton I'm a diesel technician okay all
right well
um as painful as it is and I'm I'm
hurting with you right now and I'm kind
of angry at this character for putting
you in this thing um as painful as it is
I I would stop now and let me just tell
here's an interesting story I was
22 and a guy that was in the in a
fraternity that my wife had been the
little sister to the fraternity came to
our house with Northwestern Mutual sold
me a whole life policy and I've got a
finance degree I should know better um
and oddly enough Dalton that was a long
time ago but it was 15 a month and when
I discovered like you have about a year
in that I had to stop that I'd been
screwed then I cancelled it and you know
how much of my cash value I got zero I
lost about the same amount you're going
to lose and I was 22 years old but that
doesn't mean that I would you know
staying in it would have just been
worse yeah you're going to pay 1,800
this year just paying into that thing
the bad news for Northwestern Mutual in
my case is is that I've gotten to tell
the story now for 40 years about how
they screwed me they've lost a lot of
customers than you know it's cost them a
lot more than the little bit of money
they got out of me and I've gotten
almost as much satisfaction as the money
they got out of me so it was worth it
yeah but you're not going to get that
opportunity I doubt as a diesel mechanic
you might you might tell some other
diesel mechanics not to do business with
this particular guy but yeah I'm sorry
Dalton but the actual actual proper
correct thing to do is just if you have
a hole in your pocket so up the hole
don't keep putting money in it yep yeah
that's kind of why I figured but um you
know I just want to make sure there was
no other options but you know and don't
be mad at your mom and dad they don't
know any better the financial advisor
should know better but a financial
adviser that sells universal life is not
a financial advisor a financial advisor
that sells universal index is an
insurance agent they're not a financial
adviser yeah that's what I kind of
started to learn because my parents also
are invested to him and I found out what
he has him on is also another life
insurance product so I think he just you
know he does he doesn't really do in Ms
he just sells
Insurance yeah he makes a lot of money
on it too oh M like he made as much as
you lost on this deal this year yeah
that's the other thing so I talk about
this Dave in my new book Breaking Free
from broke I have a whole chapter on
investing traps and I took a lot of time
on the permanent life insurance section
because too many young people are
falling for this it's come back around
it's got you know the Tik Tock idiots
have stepped up and are really hammering
this stuff well they call themselves
Dave tax for free wealth strategists
that's what they they don't call
themselves financial advisers anymore
cuz it's it's cooler to call yourself a
wealth strategist here's the here's the
dumb butt part of that okay
taxfree wealth strategist now let me
tell you how you get taxfree money out
of a permanent life insurance policy
number one you pay into it for years and
years and years years pass this thing
he's got no he's got no cash value right
now after a year of paying in 150 just
what we've been telling you for years
they keep it all once you get past that
you finally build up a little bit of
horrible Pocket Change piss poor returns
and you got $2,000 in there you keep
doing it for your whole stupid life and
it would be a stupid life um and you got
50,000 bucks in there you know how you
get your 50,000 bucks out
taxfree borrow it you borrow it well
guess what if you go to the bank and
borrow $10,000 it's taxfree borrowed
money never is taxed it's Dumber in hell
but it's not taxed it sounds cooler when
you put tax free in front of it that's
unbel
believable yeah of course it's taxfree
you idiot not you not you Dalton but
they they are yeah Dalton but the the
the the guy I'm a tax-free wealth
strategist well of course you are the
way you get your money out you borrow
your own stupid money out of this policy
and you pay them interest of course it's
taxfree borrowed money has never got
taxes on it that's dumb don't poke holes
in their genius strategy Dave it's a gen
there bunch of gen I'm a I'm a taxfree
wealth strategy I have a hot take for
every investment TR hot take go down the
bank and borrow 15,000 bucks that's
taxfree here's what I say I said
permanent life insurance as a wealth
building tool is a legal scam pedal by
insurance agents posing as financial
advisers it gives them fat commissions
and locks you into a lifetime of stupid
tax Dalton is exhibit a and luckily he's
getting exhibit a he's B he's B Dave did
it before it was cool now it's trendy on
Tik Tok that's why it still makes me mad
oh my goodness of course the guy the the
fraternity grow right that makes it even
worse you know how long he was in the
business about 20 minutes after he sold
our policy he was gone cuz that's how
80% of those agents are out of the
business in one year so much turn 80%
well they must lose their soul in the
first three months no they don't lose
their soul until they sold all their
family and friends there and then when
they try to sell it to individuals who
are actually using their brain instead
of the relationship to make the sale
then they find out they lost their soul
oh that's what happens and they get out
of the business they run out of steam
but the business is set up to the
industry is set up to milk your your
sphere of influence so they put you in
there as a greeny they milk your sphere
of influence your natural market and
they tell you go after your friends and
young people and college we're going to
serve your natural market oh my
gosh with a tax-free wealth
strategy shoot me brilliant just shoot
me this is the Ramsey
[Music]
Show
[Applause]
[Music]
well you've all played the telephone
game the first person Whispers a message
to the second person who Whispers it to
the third and so on around the table
until the original message has
completely changed multiply that
confusion by a 100 if you run a business
with different software systems that
don't talk to each other that's why
there's Nets Suite by Oracle in the
early days of ramsy we were using
different systems for all of our
business units we needed one single
source for accurate data Nets Suite was
the software we used to optimize and
take us to to the next level netw week
gave us the visibility into all of our
numbers so that we could communicate
across departments and plan ahead better
and as we grew it scaled with us net
week worked for ramsy and it will make a
difference for your business too join
the more than 34,000 customers who trust
netsuite to help make them smarter and
make better decisions and level up their
operations to learn more get a free
product tour at nets.com
Ramsey that's netsuite.com
[Music]
Ramsey
George camel Ramsey personality is my
co-host today deian is in Atlanta
Georgia hi Dean welcome to the Ramsey
Show hi hey what's
up so my husband was laid off yesterday
on New Year's Day um oh my God yeah
happy New Year yeah really
he he is he was a direct operation so he
was right under the owner for a Luxury
Landscaping and hardscaping um company
that works in Buckhead um they work on
Comm commercial homes and all kinds of
stuff
so the business owner um basically has
lost his behind and is dissolving
everything and we kind of have the
opportunity to not purchase the business
from him but get the equipment purchase
the equipment for from him what he for
what he owes on it and then um he will
give us his client book freely um and he
he's been very open like wants to so
he's closing up shop he's closing shop
and there's a lot of money left to be
made on the book scheduled and he's
washing his hands with it um so my
question is like how what's a lot of
money um right now they probably have
two to three months on the books and I
think there's about
$250,000 on the table give or take uh on
the table being gross revenues not
counting
expenses right correct what will those
what will those Jobs net you have any
idea I I don't know your husband's
office manager you ought to know his
margins yes yes what would it cost for
you to buy all the
equipment so um one machine he owes
$30,000 it's worth 60 another he owes
about 30,000 it's worth 60 and then he
has another machine that's brand new um
it's worth 30 and it's he owes about 30
okay what do you guys have in
money um we have about 30 to 40 35 to 40
in cash just hidden away um we have 16
in the bank and um we still owe 11,000
on his truck his personal trck
do you have to buy all of the equipment
for this deal to
happen um would he give you the client
book anyways you bought two of you
bought the two 30 over 60s and leave the
30 over 30 for him yeah he he will give
us the client book no matter what he's
very he's very encouraging and will be
very helpful it's he's very sad about
the situation you know but um he just
gave up he just gave up yes he did he
just gave up why did he lose his butt if
there's all this money laying there you
know I from an outsider perspective I
honestly I don't know but they all Drive
Porsches they have a big old house in in
Buckhead and it just looks he's he's
selling his house he's fing bankruptcy
it's just all not
good okay um well there's a lot going on
here number one let me stop with the
last state if he files personal
bankruptcy and tractor number one he
owes 30,000 on it and it's worth 60,000
he can't sell it to
you oh
okay his plan was he's told my husband
this week to take all the equipment that
is owed on back to like the tractor
company and and give it back to him and
just say here you know I'm done and
doesn't matter anything if you buy it
from the tractor company that's fine but
here's the thing anything that happens
within 90 days of him filing bankruptcy
that was an asset can be undone by the
bankruptcy
court oh okay it's called a preference
period and you're you're not allowed to
give one creditor preference over
another so for instance those voluntary
repossessions your husband takes the
equipment over there turns it in that
dealer is not going to turn around and
sell it to your husband the next day
that's $60,000 tractor for
$3,000 right and if your husband buys it
for 30,000 and it's worth 60 the
bankruptcy Court's going to come in and
say we could have got more than 30 for
that tractor and giving it to the
creditors okay and they're going to take
it away from
you yeah that's not good no okay so um
this guy he he doesn't if he is If he if
he he files bankruptcy 90 days from now
you'd be
safe okay but if he if he files
bankruptcy immediately which it sounds
like this guy's very
um
emotional impulsive
yeah and is probably gonna file soon
because he's in freakout mode yeah he's
yeah yeah probably yeah
ouch okay what if we you know what what
I would do what I would do is do what he
said to do and um see if you can talk
the dealer into selling it to you as you
take the keys over
there okay but you need to turn it back
into them and then if they it's been
repoed and what the bankruptcy court
would then have to do I'm not a lawyer
but I deal with this crap all the time
the bankruptcy court would have to come
in the trustee of the bankruptsy would
have to come in and come to the dealer
and say that repossession that you did
you've got to undo it it which they
usually won't do
that but they would undo an individual
transaction that
benefited your husband versus the
Creditor okay you see what I'm saying
yes so here's our strategy okay I got I
got I got down in the weeds there for a
minute but yeah the book of business you
sound like you are excited about it is
your
husband yes okay you think he can take
it and run it so in that case what I
would do is first thing you need to do
is do an autopsy and you really do need
to know what the crap went wrong right
why this book of business is not worth
hanging around
for okay what what is wrong what is this
guy doing is he doing cocaine I mean
what's the deal what happened here you
know I got to know if it's the business
model that's broken you don't need the
book of business of a broken business
model right no thank you but yes I'll
take the book of business if I can
figure out what caused it and if the
book of business is clean
and I can still cut the deals with those
guys and they can I can still make that
profit I'll step into that and go do it
and then I would buy one or maybe two of
these pieces of equipment with
cash okay if you can get them for 30,000
and they're worth
60 so that's more cash than we have so
that was my you have oh no you only have
30 you've got 40 and eight and 16 right
right yes two what do you guys what do
you make well he did make about 880,000
a year and we pay and I make um we paid
off all of our debt except the one truck
except the truck yes um I quit my job
working in the banking industry okay so
you let me stop you then you got 16 and
you said you had 40
other yes 41 or something 40 in cash 40
okay so you got
56 all right you get one piece of
equipment you pay off the truck and the
rest of it's your starter emergency fund
MH can you pull off the projects with
that you can rent the equipment go rent
equipment and do the project okay yes he
could rent the equipment yeah rent the
equipment cash flow the rest of the
equipment you need do not let that
dealer talk you into financing that
equipment okay don't go back in debt
it's not worth it you'll get listen if
this if this business works it will cash
flow enough to buy equipment for
cash I agree so just take your time buy
your equipment take the which which of
the two
$30,000 worth 60s is the best deal and
the best piece of equipment take that
one if the dealer will tell sell it to
you for 30 when you take it over there
and turn it in on his former boss's
behalf okay if they won't if they try to
jack it up above the loan then no don't
do it and do not buy it from your former
boss buy it from the dealer after
repo okay because the bankruptcy court
will come take it from
you okay it's like it's like buying
stolen goods from a fenced operation
kind of gotta even if you didn't know
they're stolen you're screwed when the
police come yeah we don't want that yeah
that's where you're going to end up it's
called a preference period in bankruptcy
you can look it up and you'll see what
I'm talking about but yeah I I would buy
I'd spend 30 on this and I'd pay off my
truck and I'd have a little bit of cash
and let's get going let's get going
resurrect this business yeah sounds fun
she she's got her head around it oh
absolutely that's what was giving me a
lot of hope I have hope for this
this is the Ramsey
[Music]
Show hey folks you know that sinking
feeling when you make an offer on a
house you love and then you hear there's
another offer you need the Churchill
Mortgage home buyer Edge super fast
pre-approval and a secured interest rate
plus a $5,000 seller guarantee gives
your offer the best chance of being
accepted the home buyer Edge from
Churchill gives you an advantage over
those other guys go to Churchill
mortgage.com today to learn
[Music]
more
George camel Ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at
88255 225 Sabrina is in San Antonio hi
Sabrina welcome to the Ramsey Show hi
sir how are you better than I deserve
what's up hi so me and my husband we are
on Babys set 2 we're almost done we have
about 12,000 left on our car and my
husband keeps trying to convince me that
we should trade it in because we have I
guess equity in it right now and so we
have 12,000 left I Kelly BL bed our car
it's around
22,000 he is thinking we should upgrade
to um a bigger vehicle um so this value
of the new vehicle would be
25,000 so about 3,000 more um and so I
just wanted to see your opinion I
refuseed to go to the lot because I
don't you know want to make a bad
decision so um we have about six months
left projected um until we pay it off
and he just thinks we should trade it
right now and we're going to pay it off
regardless this year um so that's kind
of his mindset I just want to get your
opinion how old are you
guys uh we're 29 28 and we've done the
stupid um 10 years of car payments and
I'm so over it but he just thinks we
should upgrade to the biggest one which
is the Yukon right now we have a a GMC
of kadia so he's want more why do you
need why do you need to
upgrade um his reasoning or you know the
big reason would just be more room uh we
have four kids and um so there's really
no trunk space um so it's I know it's
silly but you do know they have large
SUVs that are cheaper than 20 don't
you yes does
he uh yes he does okay so part of the
problem is we are not on baby step 2 you
are he's
not yeah he's wanting to stay into debt
it sounds like he's trading in one car
payment for a slightly bigger car
payment yeah like his his like view is
cuz I told him you know um you know the
way Randy does it is we we cash flow and
then we trade it in and then we pay the
difference and he's like well why don't
we just do that now and then pay it off
um all that once but I'm like no I'm so
ready to be done and he's like it's just
3,000 more and I'm like well that's just
well the Dealer's not going to give you
22 for you trade it in no that's true
too but but let's just stay with the
concept for a second the concept though
is he's willing to be in he's willing to
continue to borrow
money to get what he
wants y when he wants it
yes you got a fifth kid in the family
you didn't even know
it
yes so I don't think the car is the
issue I think the car is revealing the
issue that you all are not on the same
page okay yeah yeah and if I'm you
that's what's
disturbing because here's what you would
really do if you wanted a bigger car you
would um buy an $188,000 one instead of
a $225,000 one and that would get you
out of debt faster and you'd have a
bigger
car
correct correct yeah so I think we have
a discuss I think the two of you need to
have a discussion about the fact that
the way you feel about debt and the way
you feel when he acts this irresponsible
responsibly and contrary to what you
believe and how you want how you're you
thought we were I you know it sounds
like this honey I thought we were agreed
that we were getting out of debt and
staying out of debt and now you're
coming in here and extending the time
that we're in debt to buy something that
we obviously can't afford why didn't you
come in here and suggest we buy
something1
18,000 that is
larger because there's $18,000 isvs out
there
agreed agreed yes yeah and why didn't
you bring that in and then we to had
something to talk about cuzz that gets
us out of debt faster and we get a
larger car but instead you're scaring
the crap out of me that I'm going to
have to struggle with you the rest of
our lives on this money issue this is
really scary for me and you ought to
bring that up to him that
way okay cuz you don't really you you
know you laughed but you don't really
want to be married to a little boy you
want to be married to a man that's
walking along beside you
yeah shared goals and it it's not
cute that you're the mommy it's not fun
for you that's why I ask how old you
guys are cuz I was a little bit thinking
you were a lot younger honestly like you
were 22 or something and he still hadn't
grown up you know but um but maybe he's
29 and I but you know no I would not go
along with this I would not go to the
dealership I will not sign this I don't
believe in it you're scaring the crap
out of me but the car is not not the
problem the problem is that you would
bring this in here knowing how that's
going to make me feel that you
disrespect me on that level if I'm you
that's how I'm
feeling yeah it' be like you know let's
let's pretend Sharon Ramsey came in and
suggested we borrowed money can you
imagine how that would
go you know I mean it's I'd get
pay-per-view tickets to see yeah that
would be a hillbilly knockdown oh my
gosh unbelievable that'd be a one of
those fights right but I mean obviously
we we've had those fights long ago in
our marriage we got past them but I I I
want you I'm really concerned that you
use this opportunity to get the two of
you on the same page more than I'm
concerned about the car
transaction M and maybe bringing up we
could buy one for 18 why didn't you
bring me that is a good way to start
talking about it but most of all if I
were you I would talk about how it makes
you feel when he
um you know how it makes you scared that
that he you know he's going to mess up
everything after you guys have worked so
hard to get it cleaned up MH you know
it's just at least he didn't come in and
go I want to borrow $60,000 and buy a
brand new something you know he didn't
say that so he he's still thinking he's
siling still think he's going to get it
paid off in in a year but but you know
that means he's kind of like a two you
know on a scale of 1 to 10 right he's
not he didn't go to he didn't take it
all way make the problem slightly worse
yeah yeah but but but the big problem is
is that that's a slippery slope I mean
once you stick your toe in that water
The Vortex will suck you in you know
it's just like it's hard to go on the
lot of a car dealer and not leave
without a car it is dangerous it is cuz
they're fabulous cars and they're me
even if the Sal even if the salesman
sucks the cars are fabulous start
looking at these new features and you're
like oh man we got a lot more room these
little kids are on top of each other I'm
having to you know the one benefit
though of having them on top of each
other is you can discipline them all at
once that's easier just you can reach
you can reach them all
oh that might be a that's the parenting
style Dave used to do back in his day I
did I grew up in the day when your
mother would reach across the back seat
and you could not find a way you could
not get away there was no escaping there
was no dodging it's hard to do in the
Yukon it was Within Reach I'm just
saying well some of them have automatics
that do that now automatic moms they
just is that a thing I'm kidding that's
a feature moms would pay for I would pay
for it as a as a grandparent but there
you go just zap you in the seat if
you're misbehaving just a little z z z z
there you go oh so yeah the key here is
either sell the car private and uh
you'll she'd have 10K left after that
and they'd save up and pay for a car
with cash or wait pay it off then they
can sell it and upgrade with cash either
way or if you want to reduce the debt
okay she said she owes 12 It's Worth 22
and if you sold it for 22 and you bought
something for 18 you would only owe
eight you know and you pay that off in
less than a year yep but the that does
that's not really the strategy the the
reason for bringing that up is to point
out that he didn't bother to go that
direction it was going if he had gone
that direction I'd have actually maybe
gone with him you know saying sure yeah
you you want to move up in car and down
in debt yeah that's a plan up in size
but not in value y um actually move down
in value and down in debt but up in size
yeah I'm for that it's like people call
up and say you know we ow $122,000 on
our car and it's worth
$112,000 uh or $10,000 or whatever or
you know but it's a you know we have a
you know a tiny little Honda or
something and we've got like two kids on
the way what are we going to do well you
can move to a
$12,000 van it's a break even scenario
but don't go further in Deb people use
all these events to justify further in
debt it's so easy to justify going into
debt especially cars well Dave is for
the safety and reliability no it's not
it's for you it's for you it's for you
little boy little girl I want my TWU
that's how that's how they sound I want
my TW my
TW I'm sure your sounds like that I want
my TW my TW that's Dave's Grand kid
right there this is the ramsy
[Music]
show
George camel Ramsey personality is my
co-host today lots of things happening
here at the first of the year you know
when you get
stuck in a rut it's kind of like being
stuck in an orbit the gravitational pull
of
stupid is amazingly powerful it will
hold you in that orbit is that an
Einstein quote I I made it up it's the
new Ramsey theorem Ramsey theorem of
stupid gravitational pull but now I've
been stuck in an orbit on something you
know it's just your habit is you got a
dumb habit you got a habit of not paying
attention to your money as an example
and if and so when we're doing this
thing on this huge it's already over
200,000 people registered for it live
stream on the 11th of January it's
completely free uh and and you got to go
to Ramsey solutions.com and register for
it it's it's called breaking the cycle
and what we're doing is we're breaking
out of the orbit of stupid you got to
break the cycle and sometimes it feels
like oh it's a family cycle sometimes
people in in my world in the Christian
call it a generational curse right well
it's not a generational curse once
you're 26 it's just you're being stupid
it's in our DNA to be broke Dave it's
not in your DNA to be broke it's in your
behavior that's causing you to be broke
and you've glorified it by blaming it on
your family no you can't do that anymore
you got to break the cycle get a break
the cycle and the way you break the
cycle is with new emotions and new
knowledge and new ways of viewing things
a new paradigm and all of that comes
from intersecting with someone that can
sling shot you out of that orbit break
the cycle and that's what we're going to
do it's completely free live stream on
January the 11th and we do not want you
to miss it it's uh so 7:00 p.m. central
Time 8:00 Eastern Time make sure you
sign up because even if you can't make
that exact time we'll send you a link to
watch it and we're doing a special
giveaway with this Dave this is cool we
haven't done this before
$10,000 $11,000 to 10 different viewers
now signing up won't get you in the deal
viewing will get you in the deal because
we're giving away during the live stream
to viewers okay but uh 10 different
viewers are going to win $1,000 to jump
start their new year we're going to
announce the winners live that night as
we're broadcasting so that's pretty cool
must be present to win apparently like
that even digitally yeah you got to
register to win at ramseys solutions.com
breakthe cycle the whole thing's free Dr
John deloney Rachel Cruz George caml
Jade washaw navigating money anxiety bad
money habits that keep you stuck
practical money tips that actually work
we're going to help you break free of
the orbit of stupid that's what we're
really good at around here we are we are
good at it we're probably the best in
the world at it and um it's one of the
reasons this podcast just showed up on
Apple the other day as was the number
one podcast in the world that was
incredible out of all the podcasts
millions of podcasts in the world and we
roast to the charts thanks to you all
out there listening sub hovering around
10 or 15 sometimes up or seven up to
five but I don't I don't think we've
ever even broken three and then we hit
number one in December we beat all the
True Crime podcast out there that's
there's a lot of those it's gracious
we're in the wrong business apparently
well maybe not but yeah so hey thank you
guys by the way for spreading the word
about the show you're the ones that did
it thank you for sharing the show and
for clicking the five star reviews and
subscribing and all that kind of stuff
all that stuff helps the algorithms on
that and it drives people to know about
what we're doing here and you you are
our only marketing plan so God help us
thank you thank you thank you Tru and
you help us uh ramsy solutions.com
breakthe cycle January the 11th and uh
man we'd love to have you view it with
us Samuel is in Madison Wisconsin hi
Samuel welcome to the Ramsey show how
are you doing better than I deserve
what's
up um I just have a quick question my uh
family or my parents are in a financial
ruin and I want to uh I want to help
them out and so I just I need some help
I guess how old are you
18 what do you
make uh 37 a year what's the situ
sitation with your mom and dad
hun um well my dad has been jobless for
since we moved from Madison um four
years ago but their plan was to uh for a
summer take us out on a camper and
travel the United States and stuff but
my mom got stage four cancer so he's
been taking care of her for four years
and it's she's on like hospice and stuff
so I'm the only one that is currently
working and I'm trying to help him as
much as I can and um I'm actually
debating on getting a second job that's
one of the main reasons I'm calling
you so your 375 is supporting and he's
taking care of your mom while she's on
hospice yes but I'm getting a second job
so I'm probably gonna be pulling like
$100 a week because uh I got a bunch I
got money saved and savings and stuff
like that but I'm not paying their bills
I'm just paying for their gas they the
phone bills
like
no uh I'm living by myself yes but I'm
still paying their uh part of their pay
you're paying for their what their WiFi
the phone bill um some of the propane
how are they eating if your dad's not
working uh my dad's living off his Roth
IRA at 50 years old how much is in the
Roth uh that he does not
disclose but it's
bad what's the plan on once the Roth
money runs
out um God only knows I
mean I'm uh I'm setting up I have about
$1,500 in Investments and I just opened
up a Roth IRA because my company that I
work for doesn't getri to my 401k till
I'm 21 so what what what hour what hours
do you work
now uh third shift so I work a 7 to 7 7
P to 7 a yeah uh 700 p.m. to 7: a.m. yep
okay all right and cut can I be brutal
for just a second cuz you're in an awful
situation honey I'm my heart's aching
for you yeah how long does the doctor
say your mom's
got well they just told her that she
they they can do no more like she's
untreatable um she has a tumor the size
of a basketball yeah and the hospice is
saying she's got how long
on don't know she's just on bunch of uh
she's on a morphine and this other this
is a matter this is a matter of days and
maybe a couple of weeks am I
wrong no I mean they gave her a month to
live that was four years ago and by the
grace of God he's kept her alive so um
we're just I mean we're living on hopes
and prayers right now but I want to help
them as much as my my dream I'm not
trying to be I'm not trying to be mean
I'm not trying to break your hopes or
prayers or not I'm not messing up your
Miracle okay I'm I'm all in for that
stuff but um if that if the miracle
doesn't come it doesn't sound like she's
in very good shape to
me no she's got uh she has major edema
so she can barely walk um she's swollen
and the main reason I'm calling you now
you have any brothers or
sisters yeah but I don't really talk to
them because they do other
things no other fames
helping oh my grandparents are my
grandparents are taking care of my mom
while my dad is uh doing like side side
stuff just getting extra like he's
jobless but he's got a friend that's
hires him for like a seasonal work so
but that just got done so all that money
went towards paying off the camper in
the truck but now he has nothing
until he takes back his I mean opens up
his Ro area
again okay um your your dad is able to
work then when your grandparents are
there and if you're able I would prefer
you to spend some of your day taking
care of your mom and your dad to be
working and your dad needs to sell and
your dad needs to sell his
camper that's the um that is the main
thing that I want to get to is that he's
still living on the dream of going with
my mom and all of us and traveling the
country and that's just holding them
back yeah well you you don't even talk
you don't even talk to your brothers or
sisters you're not traveling the country
with them
oh yeah and your mom's not leaving with
hospice in a camper he needs to grieve
this dream and move forward with reality
somebody's going to have to help your
dad out hun you working more is not the
answer I think your dad has got to make
some changes and if you can help him to
make those changes and I don't know how
you do that at 18 years old big burden
that's what we pray for I I don't I
don't think you working and throwing
another $300 a week at this is fixing it
your dad's going to have to make some
moves and I'm I'm so sorry you're facing
this hun what a horrible thing to have
to go through when you're 18 this is the
ramsy
[Music]
show
live from the headquarters of ramsy
solutions it's the ramsy show where we
help people build wealth do work that
they love and create actual amazing
relationship
George camel Ramsey personality is my
co-host today as we answer your
questions about your life and your money
open phones at
225 Ray starts off this hour in Oklahoma
City hi Ray welcome to the Ramsey Show
hey
Dave watched some of your videos and
stuff uh some of your YouTube things and
I've put myself into
um some major
issues um started about three years ago
I guess when I medically had to leave my
job and it took me about a year and a
half to even get Social Security
Disability going
on uh I am retired I am retired military
and I'm drawing military disability also
but I've had to borrow from some very
highin loan places is in order to
survive for the longest time and now I
can't get out of the cycle because I
can't get a consolidation loan to pay
off all of them and refigure my cash
flow so what is your military disability
income
um let's
see okay so
so military retirement I bring home
about
1900 a
month uh Social Security I bring home
about
and disability is
39 okay on top of that okay yeah all
right so you've got you got you got
$8,200 a month coming in
yeah okay yeah the problem is with car
payment and all my
loans and rent and bills and everything
I'm shelling out about
88 okay um how old are you I'm 60 what's
the nature of your
disability uh bad knees bad back
PTSD
okay and the p ttsd is what what cost
the last
job no the knees and back is what cost
the last job oh okay okay because I just
I physically cannot work anymore I can't
sit for any long periods of time I can't
lay down for any long periods of time I
can't stand for any long periods of time
yeah um you know I just my back is
completely shot I have massive trauma in
my back and my
knees and the military has basically
deemed me unemployable sure because of
physical restraints um I'm not supposed
to pick up more than 10 to 15 pounds at
a time yeah are you are you
married yeah what does she
make uh she has
a um she does a Consulting business
for um a company and but she doesn't
really make anything everything she
makes she puts right back into it for
right
now and she really doesn't make a whole
lot because she just got started with
the
company doesn't sound like a good
deal NOP I'm pretty much having to cover
everything okay sorry I'm sorry
for I'm sorry for the Miss thank you for
your service and what an incredible
price you paid um I know and I've spent
the last two years trying to rebuild my
credit yeah well you don't need credit
credit is your problem um what what how
much debt do you
have um all
together cars credit cards
and high interest loans okay how much do
you owe on how much do you owe on credit
cards
um probably about eight and what do you
owe in your
cars the one car that I owe
on
um is still got
about 22 on it okay and
um what what is the other
debt the high interest loans okay and
how much are
those if I were to pay them out
completely um we're looking at about
25k okay all right you have 100K coming
in all right and
um so I think the challenge is is that
the two of you need to do two things one
is you need to sit down together and get
on a detailed written budget we're going
to put you into financial piece
university and into every dollar the
world's best budgeting app and I'm going
to pay for it as my gift to you to say
thank you for your service
okay okay and but you make $100,000 a
year
man yep okay you can't work because of
your physical condition so you have zero
need for a $22,000
car no that's the lightest car yeah it's
gone shouldn't make any money we're
selling it we're getting a cheap car
what do you D what do you
got um
2015 versus a note that's paid off okay
we need to get her something that's paid
off cuz y'all are broke and you're out
of control and you're going to have to
do some radical things to get in control
and that's the two of you sitting down
together she needs to get a job that
actually pays
money and then the two of you can take
the 100,000 you got coming in and the
money that she actually makes and get
rid of a car payment and then you can
clear this up in less than a year but
you don't have anything here that's not
doable but you've just all all this
stuff has happened to you and the
trauma of this whole situation is caused
you guys to to get paralyzed and you're
just not dealing with it but you've got
the math to deal with it the math is
there $4,000 $4,000 a month and you're
debt free in a year if you keep the
car yeah I know but that's the problem
is I don't you know well you got 88
coming in I do that if I do
that you know then do I so do I stop
paying on stuff and just snowball it no
we we're going and pay off one at a time
or I'm GNA pay off one of these high
interest loans how many different loans
are
there I don't know off top of my head
there's a lot but there's you know list
L list them out smallest to largest and
take out $4,000 of them this month and
take out $4,000 of them next month
that's $8,000 of the
25 right but that's the problem I don't
have I mean you have 8
8800 but that's what I'm saying so do I
take for do I just stop you pay Min you
pay minimums and you attack these but
you you're you can do this you can do
this um I think selling the car is going
to help out freeing up that payment will
give you a little bit of margin to start
this process yeah and you've got to do a
written game plan for your money you
write down $8,800 at the top of the page
or $8,200 at the top of the page and
then you work down into this you should
have there should be margin in this it
should not all be gone those interest
rates there's not enough not enough debt
here to cause that hang on we're going
to get you signed up for everything as
our
[Music]
gift
George camel Ramsey personality is my
co-host today thank you for joining us
America open phones at
225 the Ramsey Show question of the day
is brought to you by neighborly your hub
for Home Services there are a lot of
things you need to remember when the
weather gets cold thankfully neighborly
has a free winter maintenance checklist
that can help save you time and hassle
check it out at neighborly
docomo neighborly
docomo in New Hampshire she asks do your
parents' debts pass on to you after they
die things like credit cards or failed
business debt the age-old question so
the question is is any of this debt in
your name uh it sounds like no so let's
assume that there's no debt in the
child's name parent passes away they
have credit card debt failed business
debt uh my understanding is that this
would come from their estate before
anything gets paid out in the form of
inheritance if your dad lives in an
apartment and owns nothing and has
$20,000 in credit card debt in his name
it does not pass to you the credit card
company will simply not get paid he buy
he died a popper he died with no money
it does not pass to you now if he owns a
house that's worth $100,000 and he has
$20,000 in credit card debt and he dies
the credit card company will get paid
out of the value of the house before you
get a distribution so the house is sold
$100,000 20,000 goes to credit card
company you're going to get 80 if you're
the only Heir that would be the way it
works so you're right the estate would
stand good for the debts but when you
die what you own stands good for what
you owe debt does not pass
generationally in the United States
but it does come out of what would have
been your inheritance if there is an
inheritance now have you seen creditors
try to come after the family for debts
illegally unethically and illegally yes
and people get scared and go okay we'll
pay it yeah they they'll have some one
of these debt buyers that buys stuff at
Pennies on the dollar they'll buy you
know a bazillion dollars worth of debt
and then they just start calling
everybody in sight and they call you up
and they go hey you're your dad you owe
this cuz you're dad and just see if they
can intimidate you into paying it you
know your dad died and they triy to get
you to pay it for your dad you know and
uh you owe this and you're like oh well
we're going to put it on your credit
they'll threaten you and lie and all
that some of them are really really
unscrupulous there was a real Movement
by the Federal Trade Commission a few
years ago to shut a bunch of that down
um there's you know another batch of
things they find in the debt is let's
say someone filed bankruptcy and the
debt was discharged in bankruptcy court
so you don't owe it anymore legally at
all it was clear they'll still try to
collect it oh my God just to intimidate
you and you know it didn't it didn't
your bankruptcy didn't clear this so I'm
going to put it on your credit and we're
going to sue you and we're going to Gar
toe your wages and they start yelling at
you on the phone and PE you know people
that are you know uh uh I don't know
that that aren't mean and nasty like me
they'll they'll cave and give them a
bunch of money you know and so yeah it
happens all the time but but it's not a
it's that's an illegal and ethical
practice so don't fall for it yeah don't
fall for it but the the point is no you
no Lauren you don't owe money if your
mom and dad die with a bunch of debt you
don't owe their debt but it will come
out of the sale of their assets before
you get an inheritance that's the thing
to remember Ravi is in Austin Texas hi
Ravi how are you good how are you doing
Dave better than I deserve what's
up so I have no debt on my name there
were some debt I cleared it out last
year the only thing we have is our
mortgage
which currently is at
$350,000 I have a stable job I earn
around $150,000 from a job I have a wife
and two sons and I have $200,000 in a
savings account I cannot figure out if I
should invest in a real estate and then
create a passive income or are there
other better options that I should go
for I don't know if you'll like my
answer but if you filter this through
the Ramsey baby steps which people have
followed to become baby steps
millionaires you would be at what we
call Baby Steps four five and six so
invest 15% of your income we're saving
for the kids college and any extra money
we're going to throw at the mortgage
principal so we have found that one of
the keys to Building Wealth longterm is
to get a paid for house in the
mix and it's not one of the keys to
Building Wealth longterm is not keep a
200 or $350,000 mortgage while I go do
real estate that I learned on Tik
Tok got you that didn't come up that
never comes up when we interview
millionaires what always comes up is we
dump money in our 401K our Roth IRA and
we paid off our house and I've got
800,000 bucks in my 401k and my house is
worth $600,000 and it's paid for and I'm
53 years old that's a typical
millionaire and so 800 and 600 is $1.4
million net worth right that's that's
the typical millionaire so we're always
going to lead you first to be debt free
which you've done congratulations great
job second to have an emergency fund at
baby step three of 3 to 6 months of
expenses and then exactly what George
told you four five and six is 15% of
your income which is just out of your
150 income going into
retirement uh starting kids college
funds you can do that out of your 150 as
well which leaves the 200 I'm assuming
you have other money other than just the
200 and I'm going to pay off my home as
fast as I possibly can then and uh with
you I think in your situation you're
going to have a paid for home in 2 or
three years and then you can invest even
more and you can invest in a brokerage
account out retirement incredible ma'am
Robbie what I did when I when I followed
that a thousand years
ago I I am I'm still Blown Away to this
day and I know the math I know compound
interest I know what it looks like but
I'm I took an old house payment and
rounded it up 500 bucks when I paid off
the house and I put that amount of money
into a separate mutual fund and how fast
that one mutual fund was a million
dollars blows me away to this day I look
back and I go that stinking that was a
breakthrough you know and so that's why
I know the math works is I actually
lived it and walked in it the key wasn't
you leveraged debt the key was you your
savings rate your income was freed up
because you didn't have any payments I
didn't pay off the house and then spend
the house payment I paid off the house
payment and took the house payment plus
some and invested that plus invested
more but that one account just not
having a house payment how fast that one
account became a million dollars in
mutual funds just blows my mind that's
amazing it's just amazing cool goal to
have you take like 3,000 bucks a month
that's $36,000 a year going in how fast
that blows up I mean you're I'm talking
about five six seven years it just blows
up it's crazy so yeah but we don't think
about investing three $4,000 a month we
don't think about that well we're trying
to do 17 things at once that's usually
our problem exactly Amanda's in Phoenix
hi Amanda welcome to the Ramsey
Show hi Dave thank you so much for
having me sure what's up hey so um first
of all I just want to briefly thank you
for everything that you do it's so
important I remember listening to your
show when I was 12 years old on the
radio
and yeah it's now I'm 25 so I uh wasn't
really taught much about finances
growing up I kind of had to teach myself
worked at the bank for four years uh
since I was 18 and so got married young
um we've been married for six years
we're finally on the same page of like
hey finances are really important and
we're realizing we kind of suck at
managing it so um we've gotten ourselves
into a little bit of debt I feeling
overwhelmed I feel like I'm kind of in
over my head with it I'm just wondering
where to start um we've got about 30,000
in uh auto loans uh 7,000 in or more
like 10,000 in credit card debt uh but
that's it we don't have a house we're
trying to save up for one trying to get
a savings I just want to know where to
start how much in savings
uh we've got about 500 right now oh
nothing okay yeah and how much is your
household
income uh it is between 75 and 95 a year
now awesome so we're in a good place to
start doing that how old are you how old
are you guys 25 okay oh you said that
earlier I'm sorry okay yes no you're
okay all right so if we're going to
focus on one thing at a time and filter
the through the baby steps your next
step would be baby step one $1,000 in
the starter emergency fund you'll have
have that next paycheck
right okay yes then baby step two we're
going to focus on Consumer Debt so we're
not saving anything we're just focused
on paying off all of our Consumer Debt
at 40K using the debt snowball smallest
to largest balance regardless of
interest rate once we knock that out
which you guys will do probably in the
next year you'll focus on a full
emergency fund of 3 to 6 months of
expenses so those are your next steps
yeah plus your amount of selling the car
$30,000 car is really high in this
situation you may keep it but it's going
to cost you an extra year of getting out
of debt you'll Leap Frog this thing if
you get rid of that car yeah you'll move
even faster if you move down in car you
really bought too much car it's not the
end of the world but it's close it's
right on the bubble yeah something to
think about hang on I'm going to send
you a copy of the book The Total Money
Makeover to get you started restarted
after your 12-year-old listening this is
the Ramsey
[Music]
Show
George camel Ramsey personality is my
co-host today in the lobby of ramsy
Solutions on the debt-free stage David
and Ellen are with us hey guys Happy New
Year Happy New Year to you Year good to
have you guys where do you live live in
the Old peblo Tucson Arizona ah very fun
well welcome to Nashville thank you
great to be here and how much debt have
you guys paid off we've paid off
87,3 168 very good how long did that
take 2 years and 5 months very good and
your range of income during that time it
was between 91 and
$95,000 very cool what do youall do for
a living I currently Freel in
Communications and PR field mhm and I'm
a public school teacher oh very good
what grade do you teach fifth grade
fifth grade that's an awesome grade it's
a lot of fun they understand the good
sense of humor they're not quite they're
not in they not lost their minds yet
yeah completely yeah good for you
welcome very very cool what kind of debt
was the 87,000 it was the rest of our
mortgage Dave look at it weird people
it's Ramy official now house I like it
wow what is this paid for house worth
conservatively about 250 very cool and
how much do you guys have in your nest
egg in your retirement I think between
all our investments and assets and stuff
we're right hovering around half a
million all right way to go
congratulations halfway to the baby
steps millionaires way to go good stuff
okay what happened 2 years and 3 months
ago that put you on this debt-free
journey well it was about uh about a
little more than three years ago uh my
wife came to me and said I think I want
to get the house paid off before our son
graduates from high school oh I like it
and so we had about a six-year time
frame and so I looked at the numbers and
I saw that our mortgage statement where
was and I said okay divided by six years
I said oh I think we could do that then
when I dug into the numbers a little
more I said I think I think we could do
it in five years and then we started
working on we had just finished baby
step two we were working on through
three four and five and we started doing
all that as we did it and we started to
accelerate the process we started to see
this number was going to come down once
we got through baby step five which was
uh we promised to have a certain set of
number aside for Daniel's College we
sque we flew through that really really
quick and so I went down and looked at
and said you know I think we could do
this in three more years it been 12
months we got like $60,000 done and I
said okay let's just attack it so we
started attacking it and then this
summer we were on Pace to have a paid
off in March of this year and then came
out July and my wife came to me and said
we had some money in the next car fund
um we were saving up for a BB set 3B and
she told me how much is left on the
mortgage I said it's just under 15 she
goes how much do we have in the next car
fund that we could use oh about 15 goes
let's pay it off now so we paid it off
in
July and so we ended up spending the
rest of the year then kind building up
that fund backup so really kind of today
we're actually on baby step 7 now
officially a you were there you're just
buying a car is all yeah exactly well we
had a car that we really enjoyed but I
knew that we would not be able
to take out a loan to get the next car
and we do about what 30 40,000 m a year
we're heavy
drivers not not David though thank
goodness
um the automatic cars aren't out there
yet so I knew that we'd have to have
something set aside for the for the next
car so that that was great we were able
to work that out and we pretty much by
now have refilled that very cool we'll
keep working on a little bit little by
very cool it just occurs to me that the
people listening on podcast or radio
don't know what we're laughing about so
David is sight impaired right yes okay
how how much sight do you have David I'm
a I'm legally blind I'm not totally
blind so I have some things I have kind
of an idea where you guys are that kind
of stuff yeah but definitely not driving
definitely not driving or flying planes
or that kind of thing yeah elon's
working on it yeah we saw we saw the
white uh cane thing going so we knew
something was going on and we knew what
our joke meant but the rest of the team
people looking into their mic
speakers didn't know didn't know what
we're laughing at so anyway okay cool so
Daniel is with you and he's graduated
now or getting ready to graduate he is a
he's in the sophomore year sophomore you
beat the you beat the graduation big
time yeah so yeah so we got a couple
years of investing to work on and get
some things going so he'll be he'll be
ready to go sounds like he's going to
get a sweet graduation gift he's he
going to do well he's such a smart kid I
was really worried that we'd have to
really spend a lot to get him somewhere
good if not if not scholar ships but uh
we knew that was very important you know
paying off the house and and giving him
this Legacy and this this fresh start
and he's been through the process every
step of the way there's no way he's
going to have a car payment he saw Mom
and Dad sacrifice and work so hard to
get to where they are today no
absolutely not he's been he's been
through the process and he especially
has been participating lately as far as
he participates in some of our budget
meetings or he knows we talk about
things he'll hold us accountable
sometimes come we go through a store Mom
that's not in the budget or is that in
budget dad or something like that that's
fun there we go what an annoying but
beautiful piece when your son is like
Mom you really don't need to be buying
that accountability with too well he's
almost he's almost worse than me
actually he is so if I if I recount the
story
correctly um recount uh you guys were
working the baby steps
exactly and you got to 4 five and six
but in 4 five and six you just real
realized you could turn up the heat a
little bit and it six years turned into
less than three yeah it was funny it was
about the spring of the pandemic so it's
2020 and I was applying for disability
and getting rejected I was going through
vacational rehab to get my new skills
and techniques and stuff so I could be
able to get back to work and do the
things I wanted to do and that was by
the time we got a big windfall we had
you know we had the covid stimulus
checks I got disability approved so I
had a bunch of back payments coming in
at the same time of tax refunds coming
in we had a big block of money at you
know spring of 2020 we able to finish
the car so we we had financed that we
paid off the last of that sped through
baby we got through Babys set 3B mostly
Babys set 3 and then we got to five
where we had his colge fund already set
up but we hadn't really put any real
money into it lately so we committed
ourselves and say let's start this up
and so we um used a lot of that money to
kind of speed us through that process
somewhat so that we got to Babys St five
and six we're going to do those
simultaneously the initial plan but
because we got so much extra money
through her working and her school being
a quality school she gets bonuses and
things like that for the things they do
at their school and um so we end up
speeding through the instead of doing
$20,000 in like a year and a half it
took six months we sped through it
really fast and so that's why that whole
timetable went from six years to five to
four and now two and a half and it got
done so well what normally happens when
you actually put this down on paper once
you start living it and you start
winning you do end up turning up the
heat right and dialing and dialing and
dialing and dial in and dialing it's a
natural process people generally get out
of debt a lot faster than they initially
think they're going to there was times
that it came it became like a little bit
of a game sometimes we would come out to
the last week of last week of the month
we have some we think we have a limited
grocery budget okay we got to do 60
bucks this week and she's like let's do
it let's go and we'd do it in 55 bucks
or something she' be all proud and you
know we'd do these kind of things we'd
have these little games that kind of
make ourselves get our push through and
we just it was just amazing how we
started doing the budget six seven years
ago and we just kind of found our space
and said we're just going to figure out
a way to do this and do it right and we
just find money money pops up everywhere
even though nothing really changed the
sech our income it was messy messy messy
in the beginning yeah when you start
paying attention though it cleans up and
it dances it gets in a line it dances
the way it's supposed to dance it's
really really it's really been
fascinating some of the biggest things
we did was when uh we had really lean
months and yeah we weren't on credit
cards we weren going to go in the debt
but we found a way God provided us the
guidance to the GU the way for us to get
through our budget and be able to manage
and it wasn't easy we had to do we had
to drop a lot of streaming services we
had to basically had we had to read the
books we had in our bookshelves watch
the DVDs in our shelves that was really
all we entertain we had for a long time
there and now we have at least margin to
at least enjoy some of that stuff and we
can still put a good amount of money
toward stream like no one else now yes
hey we got a copy of the baby steps
millionaires book for you The Total
Money Makeover book for you and a
Financial Peace University membership
that's the live and give box uh to say
thank you for coming from Tucson to
Nashville to do your debt free scream
you guys are amazing you're Heroes I'm
so proud of you well done thanks for
bringing Daniel to share in the debt
free scream as well it's something he'll
always remember he's got to be proud of
his mom and dad and he's shaking his
head
$87,000 paid off in two years and three
months house and everything they're
weird they did it making 91 to 95 count
it down let's hear a debt-free scream
here we go guys 3 2 energy we de
[Music]
[Applause]
and that's how they do it in Tucson boys
and girls love it well done well done
this is the ramsy
[Music]
show
our scripture of the day Isaiah 43:18
and 19 don't remember the prior things
don't Ponder ancient history look I'm
doing a new thing now it sprouts up
don't you recognize it I'm making a way
in the desert paths in the
wilderness JP Morgan said the first step
towards getting somewhere is to decide
you're not going to stay
where you
are oh there it is that's kind of like
uh breaking the cycle you got to move
yeah or Breaking Free from broke that's
what we do breaking the cycle is the new
live stream that comes out January the
11th and we're giving away $10,000 10
people will get $1,000 each you can sign
up for free at Ramsey solutions.com
Breaking Free from broke is georg's new
book which comes out January 16th Jan
days lat just a couple days later so
that's the theme I guess of 2024 we're
all going to break free we're breaking
something Breaking Free Breaking Free
from breaking the cycle we're breaking
free from broke we're just breaking
something we're breaking stuff you've
liked breaking things for many decades
you want if you want if you want a cake
you got to break some eggs I'm just
saying I like is that an old timey
saying I haven't heard that one it could
be yeah could be it feels like a Sharon
Ramsey could be a really old time sing
so hey check it out guys georg's new
book comes out in just about 10 days
here and so uh if you still want to get
all the free $100 worth of goodies with
the pre-sale you can still do that
Breaking Free from broke Ramsey
solutions.com Mary is with us she's in
Seattle hey Mary welcome to the Ramsey
show thank you Happy New Year happy New
Year how can we
help okay uh so I was an idiot um I was
in love with a man that convinced me to
co-sign on a 2019 Jetta in the fall of
2021 um I'm not in that relationship
anymore um but anyway uh last summer I
convinced him to turn the vehicle back
into the dealer basically voluntarily
repossess it he could not pay the um
payment on time and I was also helping
him and he he made more than me um but
anyway so um
Volkswagen hasn't said hasn't sold the
vehicle yet at auction but when it's
sold um of course we me and him are
going to be on the hook for whatever is
left on the
loan so I want to know um if there's
anything I can do he he does have a
settlement for Harley that he uh got in
an accident and uh wasn't his fault and
he's going to get uh comp ated for that
I was also a co-signer on the Harley
because I was stupid um but that bike
has been paid off he's just waiting for
the settlement I'm wondering can I put a
lean on a settlement or what can I do I
I have text messages from him saying
that he will pay off the Jetta but I
don't trust that that's going to
happen that sounds like that's a correct
assessment to me um where was that girl
yeah oh Mary I'm so sorry what a
horrible mess oh what what a sad way to
learn a horrible lesson too isn't it
yeah how how old are you I'm 60 and he
was 43 so I had a little bit of the
share complex going on or something
there the share complex you're great
you're great okay so how much money how
much money do you
have uh how much money do I
have well I'm on baby step one I I'm
just starting out you don't have any
money I don't have any money I have
$3,000 in credit card debt that I have
uh Consumer Credit what do you
make 61,000 a year okay what was owed on
the Jetta do you know 29,000 and change
okay all right
uh all right let's just make up some
numbers for a second just to give you an
example all right let's pretend that
that Jedi when he turned it in was worth
20 on the repo lot let's pretend that it
sells for
12 okay it might get 15 for it um but um
you know we could say
nine anyway so Le let's say there's a
15,000
deficit when you're done right and they
come to you as the co-signer and they
want
$155,000 well the first thing you tell
them is what you told me I have no
money right I don't have any money I got
$3,000 in credit card debt and I have
zero cash saved and I don't have any
money that's the first thing you tell
them which is also by the way the truth
and you can tell him where he is and
where his Harley account is and that he
is getting a settlement and that they
should get the money from
him okay um and help them get it from
him that's the best thing you can do if
that doesn't work and you and I are both
suspect it
won't
right then the good news is you can
usually settle a repossession deficit
for somewhere around 10 to 20 cents on
the dollar and so if it's 15,000 o500 to
3,000 will settle it oh yeah okay so but
if you get to that point that means
you're going to a have gotten out of
debt you're going to have built up some
a little bit of an emergency fund of5 or
$10,000 or something before they get
around to bothering you with this and
then when they call and bother you you
say okay you go after him and they say
well we tried and you say well you ought
to try again cuz I got no money and uh
then they come back at you again then
you say hey uh just want to settle my
part I don't want to settle his part so
you can still go after him for more if
you want but I'll give you 1,500 for my
part and start working with them and
you'll have to Josh all back and forth
with them and argue with them some but
you probably will get it for $1,500 or
$2,000 $3,000 and then let him leave his
part there don't settle the whole debt
say I want I want the portion but but I
need inwriting from you that the portion
of my name is settled in full that I owe
nothing that I owe nothing else and you
can go after him for whatever you
want right perfect okay that's a lot
better than I thought yeah you're you're
you're in better shape it's not going to
kill you here but you do have to go
ahead and get the rest of your money
straightened up yeah and then you you
just have a 3,000 in credit card debt is
there anything
else I own a house with my ex-husband
and we both pay half of the mortgage on
it and it's probably worth about 800,000
here in Seattle but we owe like 170 who
lives in
it um myself my two sons and it's a
there's a mother-in-law apartment so the
ex lives there too um but we're not
together or anything we just yeah we get
along it works for us and that was my
choice many years ago when we divorced
so wow okay all right well then yeah
you've got that asset you don't want
them attaching that asset so you do want
to settle this right right so you do
need to get the rest of your stuff under
control so you got a little cash built
up War chest before the war
comes yes yeah wow perfect well we're
usually talking to a a an a 24 yearold
that did something like this but you can
still give anybody that's dating someone
the same warning never co-sign for
someone that never buy anything on Deb
in any way or even co-own something with
someone you're not married to would you
would you testify to that Miss
Mary I am I will preach it till to the
mountains absolutely I will never do
that and it doesn't matter how goodlook
you are and how goodlooking he is and
you know how much of a share complex you
want to have it's not worth it wow
that's a great testimony that's very
good you did you did a good job Mary
we're proud of you you be okay if you
need more help we're here to help you
okay thank you so much absolutely thank
you thanks for calling in what's your
old quote Dave testimonies a wonderful
thing to have getting getting ones a
pain in the butt y that's what Mary just
experienced with her share complex oh
that's funny oh she's great that was a
fun way to end great but yeah the the
the whole co-signing thing man dangerous
stuff obviously there's proof dangerous
stuff if you need it that puts us our
the Ramsey Show in the books we'll be
back with you before you know it in the
meantime remember there's ultimately
only one way to financial peace and
that's to walk daily with the Prince of
Peace Christ
[Music]
Jesus
n